in your undertone is saying yeah they
don't deserve to live so let's Israel
this is
exactly not what I said no no no this is
what he saying I asked a question you're
reading you you have absolutely no
sympathy for the Palestinian killing
because that's not don't put words my
wife no no no seriously I 100% have
sympathy your your entrance into this
conversation is extremely racist because
you say well Arabs have been killing
each other first of all the Arabs bassim
YF alhamdulillah Basim yusf who's on the
pbd podcast conversation is extremely
racist because you say well Arabs have
been killing each other first of all the
Arabs have been killing each other these
are called either proxy wars or Civil
Wars he did a great job and I want to
commend Patrick for finally having
someone on to represent the truth on
what's happening in Palestine in Raza
they're Israelis for a 100 days they
have brought they have dropped almost
three nuclear weapons on an open air PR
prison and all because of ham as they
say better late than ever it is
considered as part of the free war
because they are secular because they
are democratic and they are committing
war crimes every single day I understand
Pat's in a very tricky situation he's
got his good friend and co-host Zionist
Adam we pray that God Almighty opens his
heart to the truth I have never seen a
secular or Democratic country that would
actually give contraception shots to its
own citizens to their Ethiopian Jews and
make them not to reproduce and until
2013 they have confessed doing that they
have been doing this for 10 years that
is not a democratic country because it's
becoming more and more clear more and
more apparent you got people like Joe
Rogan who seem really what's going on
like they've destroyed so much have you
seen the footage the recent footage it's
crazy mosques it's just bombing mosques
bombing buildings it's so let's go to
this clip on the pbd podcast and I want
to stick with this word this term that
bosim called Adam out on that's exactly
what you're saying they're just like
poor people killing each other and we're
just like there watching them I'm sorry
that dude I like you but seriously your
undertone is [__] racist from the
beginning until the end you are looking
at those people are lesser people who
have made bad choices and because they
are poor they are okay to be bonded by
Israel now let's Analyze This this term
racist racism I have never he heard a
secular country a democratic country
that would kidnap little kids from yeni
Jews in 1950 and then take them away and
then tell their parents that they die
and they did that in order to instill um
uh citic uh DNA in their population
that's why DNA that's why DNA testing is
not allowed in Israel I mean this is the
disgusting word that nobody wants to be
called it's something ugly and it's
something that God hates I mean we know
beautifully in Islam that the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
he condemned racism as a very authentic
saying of his he said there's no
difference between the White and the
black the Arab and the non-arab
what uh separates us is our piety our
closeness to our creator Our God
Consciousness but we see this as a
pattern we see when you when you start
taking a deep dive into this you have
prominent Jewish Israelis who are
calling this ideology that uh the
co-host there Adam is upon this is a
racist ideology it's not coming from me
it's coming from it actually Israelis
Jewish people let's look at for instance
Zionism Israel racism Israel cannot be
both Israel is either a racist Jewish
state or it's a democratic state for
everybody and that's what i' would like
Israel to be I'd like a democratic
solution one state with equal rights for
um uh all its
inhabitants uh your organization Human
Rights Watch issued a report last year
uh about Israel and the conclusion was
it is an apartheid state you had a rabbi
David who was sharing his story he was
here a guest of mine on The Dean show
Rabbi and he went down to Israel and he
narrates this story and there was a
little boy maybe six or seveny old boy
bleeding from his hand he must have cut
his hand on a broken bottle bleeding and
crying and and and there was two
policemen there so I I went to the boy
and I said you know come with me and I
took him to the policeman and I said to
the policeman in Hebrew help help this
boy and they said to me why are you
talking about he's an Arab you know just
get rid of him so that was my first
experience I just replace the term Arab
with Jew imagine that he's an Arab he's
an you know just get rid of him we'd all
agree that's disgusting that's racist
and the rabbi he went into cognant
dissonance for a long time this probably
what's happening to uh to Adam when you
get in this state the truth is coming to
you and now you don't want to accept it
and now you're in this state right in
cognitive dissonance and you're you you
can't accept the the facts that are
coming to me so that's why if a person
is sincere and they want to know the
truth uh they need to take a deep dive
and he's talking about getting his facts
well we would say these aren't facts
that you're getting from Fox News every
morning I read credible sources Wall
Street Journal Fox News he's getting the
stuff from from mainstream media
propaganda machine he needs to go
outside the mainstream
okay that has a certain narrative
propaganda that they're pushing you got
to go outside of that box Israel baby's
name I think that story was refuted
wasn't it it was refed many times and it
was the biggest story what's your point
there's also an individual that I really
nominate to be on this pbd podcast
Patrick I'd love to have him to make the
connection so you have M pilled he's the
general son he's a former he was special
forces for the IDF father General in the
Israeli Army he's also using this word
racist he's also exposing this let's
hear what he has to say about this
Zionism is a racist
ideology the state of Israel is founded
on a racist
ideology Israel is an apartheid racist
violent regime that has taken over
Palestine that is
how we need to talk about it I didn't
didn't learn about Zionism in a college
course I didn't learn about Zionism from
a book my grandfather signed the Israeli
Declaration of Independence I grew up in
Zionism I know what Zionism
is and I reject it
completely you have to reject Zionism if
you have a conscience to be proud of
being a
Zionist what else is he proud of being a
pedophile I mean what is next again it's
a very ugly word it's very it's a ugly
this
gusting word and this is the root of the
issue so if you're connected with this
state here you're connected with it then
do we have a right to ask I mean is this
something that is a part is we can't
open your heart to see but is this a
part of your ideology is I mean because
you have so it's a pattern we're seeing
many people former zionists and others
who are coming out and they're using
this term they're saying this is what it
is because Israel is for Jews since the
beginning of the Bible that's number one
number two the Arabs have no right to be
there they are forcing us to kill their
children to defend our children and we
can't say this is the only Democratic
this is the only Democratic State and da
and paint this picture this fairy tale
picture and then you see how even
Christians are are treated recently
Israeli Channel 13 reporter Yosi Ellie
went under cover as a priest for a day
dressed in a robe he walked through the
old city with Franciscan father Alberto
in the first 5 minutes he was spat at
five times by Orthodox Jewish Israelis
this is the situation here Christians
and Muslims are suffering it's not
Justice in here it's not democracy in
here we are treated like a low class
people here in uh in this country in
Israel we face all kind of discri
discrimination everywhere wherever we go
you are asking Israel if it treats
Christians or Muslims different no it's
exactly the same you are the same
occupation you don't have like a human
being rights and is this all Christians
generally or anybody who is like not
Jewish I think and our friend Patrick
he's Armenian are are Syrian also and we
see how they're treated there's no
holding back even on them also those
religious extremist Jew they don't want
us basically they they tell us every
time they we don't want to get out of
Israel and uh we don't want to This Is
Our Land we don't have any problem they
have they have problem not only with
Armenians all other religious non-jewish
like Muslims Christians Assyrians not to
mention Muslims here get the out of the
country this is Jewish country only we
don't need
Muslims so when you see these clips
they're all over there you know the
truth is coming out you're not going to
get this from the Fox News you're not
going to get this from the main main
stream Source you're going to have to go
outside of it for people like Adam and
others there was a woman that was named
Zia she came out on on Israeli podcast
and he said that everybody in the kaputs
were died and then we went out and we
see the Israeli tank the one that fired
on the whole the kabut this is [__]
stories you think the IDF is just coming
in and just spraying down kutes that's
like saying American troops are just
coming into a conflict here and just
spraying down fellow Americans called
the it's called the Hannibal we'll look
it up yeah we'll look it
[Applause]
[Music]
up
[Applause]
[Music]
fore
[Applause]
[Music]
fore
[Applause]
[Music]
spe
for
[Music]
and you're going to have to listen to
people who were also putting their neck
on a line like the Miko pads uh the
Jewish historians and Jewish academics
and Israelis who also their humanity is
on their humanity is on and they're like
hey we don't stand with this this whole
idea of making it's all or none no
Israel have actually done a lot of
criminal activities that a lot of Jews
do not agree upon and a lot of the
people who go out in New York in
Brooklyn in Los Angeles these are Jewish
people shouting not in my name many of
those people are actually um Holocaust
Survivors like Gabor who was like a very
famous Hol Holocaust himself and he say
Israel is a Zionist terrorist aparte
country so so if you think like I'm
saying this because of my Muslim or Arab
background listen to the other Jews
they're saying that Israel is the
criminal here so basam YF he went to the
root he saw past you know he saw the
questions being put out and he saw the
underlining root issue what what it was
all about and this is that racism that
comes out and we're seeing the true face
of people and we see I mean the people
of humanity people who are seeing Vin
humanity is on you can see even and this
is my thing from the beginning it's the
children it's the 8 to 9,000 children
the the co-host there the other co-host
he stepped up and uh in many situations
he's also questioning he's like look at
the kids look what's happening to the
kids what what you have uh the majority
of kids who are being blown to Smither
how many people are you going to
continue to kill in order to get your
revenge all right guys so I just wanted
to touch upon that real quickly uh this
point here and I don't really see
anybody who calls himself a Christian
who exposes many of these verses from
the Bible love your neighbor turn the
other cheek you love your enemies uh
blessed are the peacemakers and you have
all of these teachings of Jesus peace be
upon and calling him the Prince of Peace
but I think here I had a I really
recommend people watch the program I did
with a Elder Pastor who kind of
dismantles and talks about how this came
about the support them Christians
because there's more Christian zionists
uh how they fell into this propaganda
with the scoffield Bible
dispensationalism he goes into the
history and then you had this con man
who went to jail came out and all of a
sudden he got his DD the Cyrus skull
field and he got funded by the Zionist
organization of America then they went
out and they printed over a million
copies of the skull field Bible and in
there the exod Jesus of certain verses
whoever blesses these blessed whoever
curs these curs and that's the bread and
butter of it many other verses from the
Bible he translate these connecting it
to the modern state of Israel and these
fakes fake prophecies is the third
temple being rebuilt I don't have to
guess about this first of all let's look
at Bible prophecy pushed prophecies that
have nothing for the first 1800 years to
do with anything of Christianity so when
Christians know this when these things
can get unpackaged and they can see that
this really has nothing to do with
Christianity these are things that were
conjured up and these are fake
prophecies this is not anything to do
with real Christianity then they would
be more inclined to show sympathy and
support rather than supporting a
modernday genocide that's happening May
God Almighty open the hearts of the
people and help them to see clearly as
many are starting to see it's not look I
used to be a Zionist I'm a as you
mentioned I'm a holocaust Survivor
Zionism was very important for me as a
Salvation of the Jewish
people until I found out that the state
was founded based on the extration the
explosion and multiple massacres of the
local population and that's not
historically controversial this is
something that's very important to look
into I'll have the this is if you want
to watch that video we're going to have
it here check this out for our Christian
friends and neighbors so they can go
ahead and get out from under this
deception this programming that they've
been hit with and that's why they're
feeling it's a part of their their Creed
their faith to support something like
this one it has absolutely as the pastor
my guest came on has nothing absolutely
nothing to do with Christianity thank
you for tuning in God bless peace pleas
be with you assalam alaykum subscribe so
you don't miss any of our future videos
hit that notification Bell peace be with
you asalam Alum we've been told that uh
they're out to kill us allam Alum
brothers and sisters we went to the
streets to ask Americans about Islam
here's what they said do you know
anything about Islam No do you know
anything about Islam No sadly do you
know anything about Islam uh not really
do you know anything about Islam
no sorry you know what Islam means Islam
uh no we've been told that uh they're
out to kill us all that's what you've
been told that Muslims are out to kill
you all well that's what they say on TV
anything I know it's in the Middle East
isn't it well then you can have four
wives brothers and sisters as you can
see there are so many Americans who
don't know about Islam we need you your
help to change that help us to build the
dean Center the first mega dawa Center
in America click to donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of
you I cannot leave without giving you a
gift if you're not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go ahead and visit theen
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1 1800
66247 52 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaikum